foreign
from the most successful sitcom in
television history to his own career on
stage Jerry Seinfeld has been one of the
most famous comedians on Earth for
nearly 50 years so why was he never
welcome at The Comedy Store the most
prestigious Comedy Club anywhere in the
country Banning the world's biggest
comedian seems bizarre at first but it
turns out there's a whole lot more to
this story
Mitzi Shore became the owner of the
world famous comedy store back in 1974.
just two years before Jerry Seinfeld
made his stand-up debut in New York City
at the young age of 22. the Manhattan as
you know is the site of the Tramway the
Tramway is this new thing that they have
on Roosevelt Island it's a cable car
that goes back and forth between
Manhattan and Roosevelt Island I think
that this is a terrific thing the cities
on the verge of bankruptcy they're
putting up rides for us and
one on the east coast and one on the
west Jerry Seinfeld admits he's short
both went on to have historic careers
each becoming comedy icons in their own
right no place else could you go you
couldn't do it on TV he could come out
here and talk about stuff that was so
bleak
but yet so funny that was great this is
a place you can do it I mean think about
all the comics that have come from that
place that your mother built what an
amazing thing if he didn't do that and
didn't give the reins to your mother who
knows what the comedy world would look
like I mean who knows of a guy like
Kennison ever gets off the ground
correct you know what I mean like you
need a place like that where it's a real
artist Workshop I mean that's a high
flute in terms well but that's really
what it is almost every all-time great
comedian over the last 50 years has made
their way through the comedy store to
see guidance from Mitzi and not even the
Ouija board could have predicted that
I'd grow up someday and be part of this
the anniversary show The Comedy Store
only Mitzi could
and the insane amount of exposure
Seinfeld brought to stand up along with
all the current comedians who were
inspired by the show makes Jerry's
offstage influence almost immeasurable
oh come on what the reason for this
rivalry has been largely debated for
years now but according to some of the
comedians who knew Mitzi best her
rejection of Seinfeld most likely boiled
down to one of two different reasons the
first theory is that Jerry Seinfeld was
already too far along in his comedy
career for mitzi's liking as she
preferred to work with newer comedians
who weren't quite as polished Jerry was
asked about his relationship with Mitzi
in a recent interview where he said
quote Mitzi Shore was a great motivator
of mine she disliked me instantly
because I was very independent and
that's not the comedy store model this
is 1980. you need to be a wounded broken
Winged Bird or you're not funny I saw
her throw a few people out there I knew
she threw Jerry Seinfeld down there
really yeah [__] Jews hating Jews
it's a [__] horror do you think
mitzi's like strong Aura built better
Comics at the store it was it was that
fear of I better not bomb yeah no other
club had that I mean Bud Freeman wasn't
doing that to Comics right but Freedom
was out there was [__] monocle eating
dinner with 10 people not bothering
anybody even though he was technically
never a comedy store comic Jerry
Seinfeld can still be added to the list
of great comedians who were made better
in some way shape or form by Mitzi Shore
even in this case where Jerry was using
her denial as motivation throughout his
career well it was that woman across the
street and ultimately got his revenge 10
years later in the early 90s did you
ever have another conversation with
Mitzi Shore or did any did you ever
convey any message to her or have any
communication I I did when I got my TV
series in the 90s I moved up to this
fantastic house in the Hollywood Hills
that overlooked all of La every day I
would drive down the hill to go to the
studio to work on the show I would see
Mitzi taking her walk on a nearby street
that we happened to have in common and I
would always give her a nice look
I wouldn't wave or hunk but uh our
Eisman
[Laughter]
and you know what maybe she was right
maybe I did need someone to step on why
did she respond that way that just
seemed so aggressive did you do anything
because I would never be the broken the
type of broken wing bird that she wanted
to have in her little chicken coop of
dysfunction what was the comedy story in
those days
I was not built like that the only one
would be a stand-up comic is because I
wanted to say to myself and to the world
I don't need you
I can do this myself and The Comedy
Store was filled with people that needed
her the second theory for this Feud is
much more direct being Mitzi straight up
did not find Jerry Seinfeld funny or as
Jerry put it he wasn't wounded enough
for her at a time where most of the
comedians performing at The Comedy Store
had more dark and edgy jokes
foreign
was an observational comic with a
relatively clean act that appealed more
to the masses it might sound insane for
Mitzi Shore to claim that a living
legend like Jerry Seinfeld is straight
up not funny but even to this day as a
69 year old comedy billionaire people
online still like to debate if
Seinfeld's stand-up career was ever as
good as his show I went and saw him at
the Palladium about a year or two ago
and it was one of the worst shows I've
ever seen like I had like a splitting
headache and I was like Furious really
and one of my friends another comic that
I respect a lot gave him a standing
ovation and I was like are you [__]
kidding me and he was like I understand
why you feel the way you do but I just
love seeing the act and I was like I
couldn't believe it and then I saw
Seinfeld again at clusterfest he was on
the big outdoor stage with a bunch of
like for kids completely different hour
and murdered like destroyed it was like
he has like corny stuff depending on
what what the audience you know is if
everyone's sitting there wearing a
yamaka he's got one act and if it's a
bunch of kids he's got he's got a cool
hip act now here's where things get even
more interesting remember before when I
said Jerry Seinfeld was banned from ever
performing at the comedy store that all
changed a few years back after new
ownership took over the store due to
Mitzi Shore's declining Health in 2018
Seinfeld returned to the store for a
surprise set that still talked about to
this day by the comedians who were there
to witness Seinfeld told this story
himself is from his mouth he came back
to the store probably five six five
years ago four years ago he hadn't been
in forever he told the story he said the
reason I hadn't been in so long as Mitzi
told me that basically I wasn't good
enough or wasn't funny enough for this
place and I just toured and did other
comedy elsewhere and then he got the
show okay Seinfeld became a massive hit
one of the biggest arguably the biggest
comedy hit in the history of Television
yeah and they used to have a house on
Kings Road or the queen Queen's
Roadhouse that's where that's where
Mitzi lives right yeah and Jerry bought
a house above their house literally just
above the house right up on the hill
above the house yeah and he said every
day he would drive in one of his
Porsches down to CBS Radford yeah and he
would slow down on purpose to see if any
of the shores were outside yeah say
hello to let them know oh I'm just
[Laughter]
coming from there yeah just coming from
above yeah right above yeah going back
down Jerry Seinfeld returning to The
Comedy Store unannounced would be
absolutely insane to witness as an
audience member but the story gets even
crazier when told from the perspective
of Tony Hinchcliffe the comedian with
the tall task of following Jerry
Seinfeld after that legendary set I had
to follow Seinfeld at The Comedy Store
toughest follow I ever had in my entire
life because all he did was talk about
how Mitzi the owner oh that's right told
him he wasn't funny the last time he was
there that's right you were there for
that set crushing he buried me with a
shovel nothing like it ever because he's
telling them the whole story so even if
the people didn't know how big of a deal
it was that Seinfeld was in the or The
Comedy Store he told them this lady told
me I wasn't funny I wonder how she's
doing now all this stuff like and she's
like everyone knows she's sick and old
and I bought a house above her house so
that she could see me driving a
different car all the time I beep as I
went by still not funny I mean he's
destroying destroying it was like evil
cool I was buried with a shovel and
everybody
seventy percent of the people left the
room the other thirty percent were
literally texting their family I just
saw Seinfeld make his return to The
Comedy Store that he hasn't been here in
35 years he just told the whole story
I'm performing I remember a fruit fly
the only laugh I got the set was from a
door guy or whatever because a fruit fly
went in front of me real slow in the
lights and it was all lit up I go even
the fruit flies getting out of here but
that is the craziness of Mitzi Shore how
could she say no to Jerry Seinfeld even
when he went there he was already like a
solid comic and that's the thing that
they say is that when you used to tell
Mitzi like oh this guy's a big deal from
New York that she'd be like well I'll
see for myself when you really think
about it it's pretty crazy and kind of
sad that these two could never end up
seeing eye to eye despite dedicating
their entire lives to the exact same
thing comedy Mitzi Shore passed away on
April 11 2018 obviously ending any
ongoing beef with Jerry Seinfeld both
Mitzi and Jerry are still thought of as
all-time greats amongst comedians to
this day and their influence is visible
all over the comedy scene I've hung out
with some of to say we're buddies but
I've hung out with them a few times
because of Comedy he's like wise and he
does he does TM you know and he doesn't
drink and he's like centered and he's
got a family and he loves comedy and
he's got his money and it's just he's a
good guy to look up to as a as a as a
comedian and like a business person
where you want to be and as a man where
you want to be in life and how you want
to be and what you want to be like let
me know in the comments if there's any
comedy beefs you'd like us to cover in
the next video also let me know in the
comments how many times Mitzi Shore has
banned you from The Comedy Store that's
right you thanks for watching
at joke world
and the world is wrld
[Music]
foreign